well let's uh take a look and we're
going to find out
not sure but we will certainly keep a
close eye on it sam henches it'll be his
fifth appearance his very first major
league start
he did get his win against the new york
yankees
swinging a pop to shallow center rosario
broke back he's got to race in and make
the catch
for out number one in a while i would
say
that's off the outside edge and rizzle
take his base so he works the walk
let's see if the cubs can score first
javier baez coming up
the 1-2 slowed it down and swing and a
miss struck him out
two on two out on the one-two pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out with
a fast ball to end the inning
zach davies facing these indians today
what comes to mind
well i i think establishing his fastball
first and foremost and
throwing it on either side of the plate
four strikes
next delivery swung on line to the gap
and right center this will get down for
a base hit
it's going to go all the way to the wall
hernandez on his way to second he'll
pull up with a double
square peg into the round hole or
whatever that saying is there's a
smash to second off the chest of soul
guard and he won't get him at first
rosario hustling down the line beats it
out the stretch for the strength two
pitch here it comes
swinging a miss a beautiful changeup it
ended up down near the ankles but when
it came in it was looking like
it was around the thigh or the knees
got him to swing and miss it that one
and he pitches his way out of it
good job
and he did struck him out three in a row
for hinches
one down here in the second 3-1 pitch
and the ground ball weakly hit to third
ramirez goes to second for the inning
ending force
so the frustration for the cubs
continues
no score middle of the second
josh naylor bounces one to rizzo to
begin the bottom of the second inning
rizzo gloves it feeds the ball to davies
on the back
and that's on me you know and i i feel
like it's going to be a tougher pitch to
get to
ponded out in front of the plate davis
jumps on it throws to first
[Applause]
tapped out in front of the plate
contreras gobbles it up slings the first
inning
over managing his overall workload
that one lifted high in the air left
center field
long run rosario and it'll bounce for a
base hit
and the first pitch low and outside for
ball one
and running to second and making it
safely is contreras
he saw that ball bounce off the glove of
rivera the pitch in the dirt
swing and a miss he struck him out
anyway
and another hitter goes down flailing
with a runner in scoring position for
the cubs
two men are on with two down for jason
hayward and the 1-2
slow breaking ball struck him out
and sam henches continues to walk the
tight rope and make it to the other side
weekly pop shallow center dropping it's
gonna get down
on the ground rizzo they get one there
back to first they get
two there nobody turns that better
here's the 2-2 swung on popped him up on
the infield
the second baseman hernandez under it
and he makes the catch drifting back
into the outfield grass
right back up the middle step on the bag
for one throw to first oh what a play by
bowers to dig it out
and a double play ends the inning is
that you'll throw it well
so you can sit there and say throw it a
ton but he's got to throw it well
that worked little tapper and gets
naylor to bounce into the double play
[Applause]
swing and him as he struck him on and
sam hinches with his sixth
strikeout of the afternoon swinging in a
miss hey struck him out
with a slow slider and that
ends the inning as davies gets set to
deliver the one two here it comes
swung on and missed strike three
runner goes and the throw
got him
so bowers cut down a strike come out
throw him out double play and that is
the inning
oh my that is hit a ton deep
right center field on the track at the
wall and making the catch
is ahmed rosario for route number two i
think it's safe to say the ball
is not carrying today that ball i
thought was going to be in the bullpen
it sure seemed like he got all of it
didn't it no score
sixth inning two down bases empty for
elder mauro vargas 2-2 pitch on the way
to vargas
a swing in a line drive deep right field
that ball's going to be in there it's
going to roll up against the wall near
the corner
vargas hot footing into the into second
he will stand with a double
here's jack peterson trying to drive in
the game's first run
and that one ripped out into right
center field a base hit
vargas coming in to score peterson to
second
jock delivers and the cubs lead one
nothing
as he gets this breaking ball away and
hammers it to right center
back to back doubles now we'll see if
the indians can counter this has been
their beginning of the year there's a
drive to deep left field and it is off
the wall
and duffy got pinned up against the wall
so it's an easy
lead off double for cesar hernandez
amanda rosario to the plate one for two
of the single
and we'll see if they can continue that
as a men rosario yanks it into the left
field and we are tied at one
cesar races home ahmed's going for two
and he goes in safely with an rbi double
the indians answer back quickly it's 1-1
swing and a base head out of the right
center field
contreras makes his way to third baez
gets
just enough of it and they're at the
corners
the bags are now loaded for the cubs
jason hayward
is at the plate fly ball right field
playable for josh naylor
and the cubs leave them loaded well
we're going to the night dinning
here's a 2-1 and that one is ripped into
right field for a base hit
good job by contreras go ahead run his
eyes this will put two men on
as bios makes his way to the plate
broken background ball to short there's
one and they're gonna have a tough time
they don't turn it not a good throw by
jimenez otherwise that's
an ending ending double play the
unturned double play right there
keeps the inning going shattered bat
bouncing ball to second the barrel went
whizzing past class a
and the inning is over
swinging a missed chafing gets him and
so now here we go 10th inning cubs will
start with a runner at second base
ildemar
vargas coming up and they've got two on
and nobody out
he squares again with two strikes and
that's it he strikes out
16th pitch of the inning popped him up
[Applause]
ramirez calling for it ximena says i'll
take it he does too down
it's up to eric sogard the number nine
hitter
struck him out with a curveball he froze
him
and karen check dances off the diamond
at the same situation the comes at
two on nobody out
perfect but see that was absolutely
perfect
bases loaded five-man infield
and cesar will try to end it
popped up baez makes the grab that's out
number two
rosario will bat with two down to the
bases loaded on a wacky
10th inning and the game is still tied
at one the set the pitch
a swing and a line drive to right field
base hit down the line
game winner ahmed rosario
and the indians get their second walk
walk-off
win of the year a two-out
rbi single down the right field line
by amanda rosario